[Music]
hey everyone my name is Jeff Sharkey and
I'm a software engineer on the android
framework team and today we're gonna be
digging into files on android and all
the various places that android gives
you to store those files so today we'll
dig into starting by looking at some
common locations that Android offers the
first broad category is internal storage
and these this storage can be classified
as safe and secure because it's
something the Android OS protects it's
part of the application sandbox model
that we offer you've probably
encountered some of these directories
before like context get files derp it's
a great default location to store things
one that's slightly different is get
cached err well dig into that a little
bit later today but one thing to note is
that files that you store in that
location the disk space is not counted
against your application and the reason
for that is that Android reserves the
right to go in there and delete some of
those files if the user needs that disk
space elsewhere so it's a trade-off it's
a two-way street another directory get
no backup files derp this can be useful
if you have things like cloud messaging
tokens that you want to renew when your
app migrates between devices um so it's
a great if the device goes through a
backup and restore phase those files
that you store in that directory they
won't be carried across the backup so it
can be useful for that finally get code
cache directory this is a great place to
store things like jaded code or
optimized code and the OS will do two
things it will delete contents inside of
the directory under two conditions
either when your application is updated
via Play Store or whenever the OS itself
receives an upgrade safe from the oh
release to the P release it will clear
the contents of that directory so that's
a summary of the internal storage next
the other broad category of locations is
external storage and when we think of
external storage it's more of a shared
area and it's unprotected and the reason
I just mention that is data that you
store in that location you may write it
there but other applications can request
the storage permission on android and
they may write that data or modify it
with
you knowing about it and so it's
something we definitely discourage
storing sensitive contents in that
location if you do need to store data
out there consider finding a way to
prove to verify the integrity of that
data if you need to trust if you need to
trust it the directories here files
they're similar to internal storage
cache they're the same way external
media ders data that you save in there
will be scanned by media store on the
device so it's a good place to store
photos or videos that you want to be
included in the users gallery
application to be scanned and included
there get OB beaders io b b stands for
opaque opaque binary blobs and these are
these are large files typically used for
game developers that are delivered
through Google Play data that you store
in those locations they're counted
towards your apps code size instead of
its data size so so far we've talked
about broadly internal storage and
external storage and these are all great
places for you to store data that
belongs to your app but you might find
yourself creating data that belongs to
the user that the user may want to store
in a different location and that's a
great place to use the storage access
framework and there's two intents that
work great their intent action open
document and create document these have
been around in the platform since the
KitKat release and you can think of them
as an open and a save dialog box for the
user it really offers a great experience
because the user has control over
exactly where those files are stored on
the device it gives them the freedom to
choose any of those locations it also
opens the door for cloud storage
providers you don't have to integrate a
cloud provider SDK into your application
you just simply launch the intent and
the user can select where they want that
file to be stored there's some great
talks that have dug into this elsewhere
so I'd encourage you to search around
online there's some great content that
digs more in depth so we talked about
some basic locations let's do a deep
dive on two specific advanced locations
today one that we'll dig into is direct
boot and the second we'll dig into is
cache data it's the first direct food
which you may not have encountered
before and first it's worth starting out
like we built we built the direct food
feature in the Android and release to
solve an important problem when before
the end release when we encrypted
an android device and if the user
rebooted that device no apps could run
until after the user had entered their
credentials a PIN pattern or password so
what we did in the end release is we
created two storage areas that they're
still encrypted but they're encrypted
with two different keys and we call
these areas the device protected area
and the credential protected area the
device protected area becomes available
by virtue of the device proving that it
hasn't been tampered with so when the
device boots up there is DDM verity
verifies that the device hasn't been
tampered with by virtue of proving that
it unlocks that that device protected
storage then later when the user enters
that pin pattern or password the
credential protected storage becomes
available for applications to use if you
haven't encountered these api's before
rest assured that all of your data by
default as an app developer is always
stored in credential protected area but
if you if you find a place where you'd
like to run before the user has unlocked
their device that's where it might be
useful to store small bits of
information out in that credit out in
that device protected area so that your
app can be useful while the device is
locked so then you might ask the
question how do you gain access to that
storage area on the credential protected
area as I mentioned context get files
dirt offers that credential protected
area there's a method on context and you
can see it down here at the bottom of
the screen create device protected
storage context it's a little bit of a
mouthful what it does is it returns
another different context where the file
API is referring to internal storage on
that returned context point at the
device protected storage so let's take a
look at some code examples of how you
might integrate with those ap is one of
the first things you'll need to do is if
you want to become device direct boot
aware is to think about what data you
want to keep on credential protected
storage or migrated out to device
protected storage so a lot of you will
be writing code like this to decide
during that initial upgrade step how you
want to migrate data back and forth the
first thing you'll probably do when
starting your application is ask is the
user currently unlocked has that pin
pattern or password been offered so the
user manager class offers you can check
is the current user on law
assuming that they are unlocked that
means you have access to both the device
and credential storage and here we can
see theirs to move methods that are
offered as helpers you can move shared
preferences between two locations and
you can also move databases back and
forth the reason the reason we provide
these helper methods is oftentimes
shared preferences or databases can
actually be made up of multiple files on
disk and some of that data may also be
cached in memory so by calling these
helper methods to move that data data
around we ensure that all the data gets
moved and that any any in-memory caches
aren't validated along the way what do
you think about data that you would want
to migrate I one thing we say is only
move the data you think you need to
provide that user experience while the
device is locked so things like if
you're building an alarm clock app you'd
probably move the users next alarm time
out into that device protected area to
make sure the alarm clock would go off
if the user user's device is currently
locked another strategy that we've seen
used if you have auth tokens to talk to
a server we've actually recommended
people create a second type of auth
token for your cloud server i1 auth
token is a full rich full access token
which you probably use today we'd
recommend keeping that in the credential
protected area and creating a second
much more limited in scope auth token
and only storing that limited in scope
off token out in the device protected
area maybe that off token when it talks
to your server back-end is only able to
return the fact that the user has three
unread messages and maybe it can't do
any operations beyond that so it offers
it helps you deliver the experience of
getting the users attention when you
need to but without without being able
to access any of the additional richer
information in your cloud ok so we've
talked if it's unlocked we can migrate
data back and forth the else clause here
we'd recommend that you register there's
a runtime broadcast that sent an action
user unlocked and that would allow you
to then run code when you're actually
when the user on the answer is that pin
pattern or password the middle code
snippet here those move methods they
work both directions so if you
accidentally moved a right move some
data out into the device protected area
you can also move it right back into the
credential area and another tidbit
another API that might be useful at the
bottom of the screen there if you're
ever wondering if a particular file is
going to be encrypted at rest
by the operating system you can quickly
check for that as well there's a storage
manager is encrypted API and that can be
useful if you're trying to decide if you
want to roll your own encryption or rely
on the encryption at rest that the OS
provides all right so a second deep dive
area that we'll dig into is cached data
on the US and this is typically data
that you can regenerate or redownload
later on if it happens to be deleted and
I mentioned earlier that this is a
two-way street
the OS won't count the data that you use
in that area against your app but at the
same time we reserve the right to go in
there and delete some of that data if
the user needs at the disk space for
something else that they're doing um and
something that we improved in the au
release is we rewrote the algorithms
used internally one of the biggest
questions we got from you from
developers was how much calf space is
appropriate to use is can I use 500
Meg's if is that too much is 50 Meg too
much so now we offer explicit guidance
there's an API on storage manager to
figure out a cache quota for your
application a reasonable amount that to
think that the device thinks is
reasonable for your app to use and the
nice thing is the OS adjusts that value
over time so if the user spends a lot of
time in your application we're going to
increase that number to give you more
cache space to work with so that you can
offer a better user experiences to the
to your users another thing that we did
in the OU release we rewrote the
internal implementation of how that data
is cleared before the OU release we
would literally list all of the cache
files on the OS sort them by modified
time and delete the oldest files and you
can imagine that there were ways you
could GameA Phi by setting your modify
timeout to like the year 2038 so we
fixed that and so now in oh and future
releases I the OS will delete data from
apps that are most over their quota
first so what this means if your app
stays right around the cache quota that
the OS has recommended you can be pretty
confident that your data will be there
and will remain available um even as the
user starts filling up their disk so
what are these let's look again at some
code snippets like how would we use this
in practice so again going to storage
manager if you're integrating with a
common class say like disk LRU cache
it's pretty easy to connect the two
things together you can
the US for that recommended cash quota
bytes and plug it straight into the
discolor you cache to help it trim how
much size it's using if you have
multiple types of caches it's up to you
to decide how you want to fractionally
account or distribute that cache amongst
your the inside of internals of your app
the second code snippet there if you're
rolling some of your own caching point
out there's a method called get cache
size bytes this is a fast way to ask the
question how much cash space your app is
currently using on that it's an
optimized call that will turn very
quickly and it's faster than you having
to go iterate over your own disk usage
to try to figure out how much space
you're using another feature that we
added in the overlays which is covered
at the bottom half of this slide is the
ability to have cache behaviors and we
heard this from developers that it can
be useful you'll you may download
multiple files that really should be
treated as a unit or a group one
concrete example is downloading say a
movie file and a subtitles file that
goes along with it if you store both of
those in the cache directory if one of
them gets deleted the other file isn't
really useful and valuable so the cache
behavior offers you a way to indicate to
tell us as the operating system that if
we need disk space we should delete both
of those things at the same time all
right so we talked about some of the
common storage locations let's switch
gears and talk about how we can work
together but the OS helping you as
developers and one of the biggest things
that we offered in the O release is the
ability to help you get the disk space
that you need before the o release if
you wanted to do a large download let's
say one gigabyte in size and if you
looked just at the free disk space you
may only see 500 megabytes were free and
it may look like that download was
impossible but there's a new API in the
o.r Alize where the OS will offer to go
and delete cache files belonging to
other applications to help free up the
disk space for that operation to succeed
for your application if there still
isn't enough disk space there's new
intents that you can launch to help get
the user involved to help them pick
items and different things that they can
do to help free up that disk space so
how do we use this API here's a snapshot
of this the very top of this slide this
is maybe the way that you've been
writing code today you'll just do a
pretty simple check you have a download
size you're comparing it against Java IO
dot file
that get usable space how much to space
is there that's the operation that may
look like it wouldn't be possible to
succeed but if you convert your code to
using the rest of the code snippet on
this slide if you call the Storage
Manager get allocatable bytes API that
will return not just the free space it
will also include space that the OS is
willing to go free up on your behalf
from other applications cache data so in
this case it may look like if we have
enough space inside of that if block we
can actually open that file output
stream and now there's an API called
allocate bytes and what this will do is
it will go actually claim that disk
space for your application deep
underneath it'll use the F allocate
system call to ensure that those blocks
belong to your application and that you
do have the space that's guaranteed to
belong to you so that could be a useful
useful API to use and the else block
here if there still wasn't enough space
we know are for some great intents for
you to ask the user for help to come
along and free up information and free
up the disk space sharing content we've
covered this a little bit before how can
we work together there please always use
content you rise when you're sharing
between applications never use file your
eyes and the reason is that receiving
application they may not have the
permissions that they need to directly
access the files on disk if you use
content your eyes the OS can manage the
dynamic permissions to give the
receiving out to make sure that they can
open the content if you find yourself in
this position file provider in the
support library is a great way to
convert between the two with a single
line of code
every place to convert from file to
content and over the years because this
is an important important thing to pay
attention to we build strictmode api's
to help you track down and detect these
places in your app you can detect places
where you might be accidentally sharing
file your eyes and now I own over more
recent release you can also detect
places where you're sharing a content
URI and you might be forgetting the flag
grant read or the flag grant right to go
along with that intent so those can be
two AP is that are helpful to look at
native code is another area to think
about we'd strongly recommend that you
look at opening files up in higher-level
managed code up in Java or Kotlin and
passing down the already open file
descriptor the integer down into native
and the reason for that is opening it a
managed code gives the OS the
opportunity to notice and inspect
incorrect things in particular can look
for strict mode violations if you open a
managed code it may notice that the
thread that you're currently running on
is important to the user is may block or
cause jank in your app and we're gonna
start using this more in future Android
releases so this is why we want to
strongly encourage open the file in Java
or the higher-level language past the
integer down to native code don't pass
the file path itself across the j'ni
boundary and a quick code snippet of
what that looks like you can pretty
quickly do this with partial file
descriptor you can open a particular
file on disk maybe for read/write in
this case and there's a method called
detach FD that will return that integer
it's just an int that is ready for you
to pass across a J&I boundary as a giant
so that's the recommended design going
forward another note that might be a
trick or a tip that could be useful if
you find yourself just jumping across
j'ni to do a handful of system calls you
might go look at Android system OS there
are several dozen POSIX sis calls ready
for you to use up in Java today we only
added that a couple releases ago so you
may be able to find that you can do
those handful of sis calls purely in
Java and you may be able to get rid of
the J&I on the native code in your
application so take a look at that and
finally working with media um we don't
really recommend that you use media
store if you're looking to find the
photos or videos that the user has on
their device and there you might be
tempted to go and build your own index
of whatever media you find but that can
be pretty wasteful of both of CPU and
battery for the user and another note is
we're actively working on improving
media store and really adding
functionality there so stay tuned over
the next couple releases another note is
open files open the the content of that
media through content resolver
you may have noticed that there are
columns across the operating system
called underscore data and they return a
file system path over time you may have
noticed that a handful of those
underscore data columns have been
deprecated in previous releases and it's
just to expect that's going to continue
so you'll notice more of those
underscore data columns becoming
deprecated over time
we really want to encourage people to
move towards content your eyes as a best
practice so yeah that's thank you for
your time
being able to dig into some of the
nitty-gritty areas of storage and I'll
be available in the Q&A section
afterwards if you have questions for me
thanks for your time
[Applause]
[Music]